le confinement aura été une période
pleine d'enseignements parmi ceux ci
nous avons pu constater le fossé
grandissant entre certaines célébrités
et leurs audiences
est ce la période qui a rendu le public
plus irritable ou simplement les
personnalités ont-elles enchaîné les
maladresses sans doute un peu des deux
toujours est il que rarement des
célébrités ont été si bousculés
notamment sur les réseaux sociaux
le phénomène a commencé aux états unis
où des appels aux dons et à la
générosité venant de personnalités
fortunées ont été perçus comme indécent
par une partie du public
si le virus ne fait certes pas de
différence selon la notoriété des
individus qu'ils frappent les images de
stars faisant oeuvre de charité au
moment où les plus précaires était en
première ligne face à la pandémie
ça ne passe pas cette journaliste du
guardian explique pourquoi il n'a jamais
été aussi clair à quel point les
personnes qui gagnent le plus contribuer
peu à la société on est tous ensemble
continue de nous dire les riches et les
célébrités
désolé mais il est clair que nous ne le
sommes pas en état de faire relayée par
la presse américaine dont cet article du
new york times intitulé le culte de la
célébrité brûle pour exprimer le malaise
provoqué par ce décalage entre le
quotidien fed angoisses du plus grand
nombre et la parente déconnexion des
célébrités des internautes ont utilisé
un hashtag sans équivoque guillotine
2020 un mot diez qui existait déjà
depuis des 1017 comme le révèle le
quotidien le monde mais qui a pris une
dimension nouvelle avec l'actualité
cette référence révolutionnaire ne
pouvait évidemment pas échappé au pays
des sans culottes
le mot clé est apparu dans les messages
d'internautes français derrière
l'apparence violence à laquelle renvoie
l'image de la guillotine l'expression
vise surtout à exposer cette fameuse des
connexions teintées d'indécence que
ressentent certains en france
ce décalage a eu plusieurs illustrations
l'une des premières fut le journal de
confinement de l'écrivain leila slimani
publiée dans le monde
la romancière est décrit son quotidien
visiblement certains n'ont pas apprécié
ils n'ont trouvé personne d'autre que
les la slimani pour nous raconter les
bienfaits de son confinement bourgeois à
la campagne la plupart d'entre nous
aidant
fermée à plusieurs entre quatre murs
vous croyez qu'on a besoin de dire ça il
ya aussi eu cette tribune du monde
co-signée par des dizaines de
personnalités portant ce message non un
retour à la normale un texte qui appelle
je cite les dirigeants et les citoyens à
s'extraire de la logique intenable qui
prévaut encore pour travailler enfin à
une refonte profonde des objectifs des
valeurs et des économies un ton perçu
comme donneur de leçons alors même que
certaines de ces personnalités
signataires ont bien profité du
consumérisme qu'elle dénonce aujourd'hui
comme l'ont relevé certains internautes
qui ont notamment ressorti d'anciennes
campagne de publicité les citoyens ne
sont pas idiots elie saab
quand les gens sont sincères quand ils
sont avec le peuple parmi le peuple dans
le peuple et ils ne se sont pas du camp
quand les personnalités comme ça qu'ils
ont général n'ont pas beaucoup de
conscience politique se réveille à
l'occasion d'autres crises et découvre
un petit peu l'eau tiède découvre qui a
des premiers de corvée c'est normal
qu'il y ait un divorce entre tout ce qui
est représentatif ou jugés comme tels
dans la société française s'est affichée
d'abord le monde politique
un petit peu le monde syndical puis le
monde médiatique est aujourd'hui
largement tous les people qu'on voit un
peu toujours les mêmes sur les plateaux
de télévision
ce rejet exprimé sur fond d'imagerie
révolutionnaire n'est pas né pendant le
confinement mais il a été accentuée par
cette période
reste à voir si cet état de fait
perdurera on a fort à parier que de ce
point de vue certains espèrent un retour
à la normale